you know who you look like John
Malkovich he got the same head and
everything except where Malkovich has a
great expressive face yours has no
expression ever it's honestly a bit
creepy your sense of humor is as sharp
as ever you like that one how about this
one so three guys are lost in the desert
that please do not attempt to divert my
attention my time is limited
mine isn't I've spent the past three
months lying on a hospital bed staring
up at the ceiling not much new here and
I spend a lot of time thinking though
would you like to leave that hospital
bed what do you mean dr. Valdez's dead
oh [ __ ]
what about the little girl her fate is
undetermined at this time given a danger
she possesses even while in a coma
termination may be necessary let me
guess you want me to finish the job
negative if termination becomes
necessary another agent will be assigned
that duty however my superiors asked me
to investigate your background further
given recent events please take a look
at this I haven't seen that picture in a
long time I don't know what I was
thinking with those sideburns I have a
proposition for you dr. clef there is an
SCP on this facility that has been
problematic as a blade terminating and
has proven to be difficult if you will
do us the favor of eliminating it I am
authorized to offer you twelve minutes
of exposure to the locket which should
be sufficient to heal your injuries in
addition I will grant you level four
clearance on all SCPs at a permanent
position with a support staff of up to
six employees I don't need a support
staff maybe an assistant but uh that's
it then we have a deal just one
and what would that be
I want a nifty hat